the jurogan experience
so explain the process so you were uh
what was the exact uh definition of what
they kicked you off for oh are we are we
live yeah we're all good good okay um uh
all right
so it was almost exactly this time last
year joe it was august 28th 2021 uh i
uh wrote a tweet that began it doesn't
stop infection or transmission
and they banned me
i went on to say uh this is not a
vaccine or don't think of it as a
vaccine think of it as a therapeutic
meaning a drug that has side effects and
that you have to dose in advance of
illness
and then the last line was and we want
to mandate it insanity
okay i i would say that that's been
pretty well vindicated by events that's
that's vindication
so so they banned me they said that was
my fifth strike
and that i was not allowed to tweet
anymore and my account was not available
to anybody all the previous tweets were
gone
the 300 000 people too bad
um
so i sued them
uh in december
and
here's it gets it gets interesting and
tricky uh
so other people have sued twitter and
facebook and youtube uh and wikipedia
actually all these companies um
and said you know you've banned us uh
uh
you know
i just want to be able to use your
platform i haven't done anything wrong
and the companies say we can do whatever
we want we can ban you we can you know
attach labels to your tweets this that
and the other
uh and there's a law called section 230
of the communications decency act it's a
federal law from 1998 i want to say
maybe 96
that basically
was intended for two purposes purpose
one was
we don't want these companies to get
sued over stuff that people are saying
on them so in other words i go on and i
say you know terrible things defamatory
things about joe rogan or i say terrible
things about my ex-wife whatever okay or
i say you know go shoot the president
whatever it is i'm saying i'm saying
something that's harassing or hateful or
illegal we can't expect
uh a bulletin board or facebook or
uh or
or twitter or whoever to police all that
stuff there's too much of it it's not
fair so we're gonna give them complete
protection from that and that makes
total sense by the way all right you
can't you know you can't have these
people uh policing everything that's
uploaded or downloaded it's not it's not
within their capability okay the second
idea was we want these folks to be able
to give their users a better experience
and so we're going to give them some
protection limited protection to
moderate the content that's posted
meaning
let's say i'm posting tons of
pornography and you know i'm posting it
to a christian website that uh
that you know that's advertising itself
as a family-friendly place
the idea was the uh 230 is going to
allow me to take action against
uh that user in good faith for harass
harassing or objectionable content so
i'm gonna be allowed to ban stuff or to
age restrict it
and and that was really intended when
you look back at the statute for
pornography especially okay
so what happened was the companies with
the help of the ninth circuit which is
uh the the federal uh judges in in
california which is where most of these
companies are based
california and the west coast uh managed
to get
bigger protection and this really this
was happening for a while and then it
really happened in 2015 there was this
case
where a group of sikhs uh you know an
indian minority group the government of
india went to facebook and said we don't
like these people they're protesting
against us you gotta ban them you gotta
ban their their group website and
facebook said okay and pulled them
they sued facebook they said this is not
right and by the way like this was a
classic example of a government
telling
uh you know didn't not wanting dissent
okay they didn't facebook the indian
government didn't want to deal with this
group so they told facebook to ban it
okay
the ninth circuit said
that 230 protection
that allows you
complete immunity
if if alex berenson says you know here's
naked pictures of my my ex-girlfriend
that also allows you to ban whoever you
want whenever you want
they called it first party third party
they said there's no distinction in the
statute between the immunity you get
for
uh you know for for this for this
defamation that alex might be doing
versus your own decision to ban these
people who don't want to be banned and
ever since then 230 has been a beast
and every time somebody has sued the
companies have said look at seeks versus
facebook
we win
and that's basically been how it's been
they've been allowed to do whatever they
want and so by the way i know i'm not
even talking about my case yet but this
is the legal background so sometimes
when conservatives say hey we need to
ban 230 we need to repeal 230. i that's
actually not true you just need to have
the courts interpret 230 the right way
which is you don't get to sue facebook
or twitter for these defamatory or
harassing or illegal posts that other
people are putting up but at the same
time they shouldn't have blanket
protection for their own decisions so
they've had the best of both worlds they
call themselves publishers when they
want and as a publisher i have the
protection to publish who i like not
publish who i like but i'm not a
publisher for the point from the point
of view i'm more like a telephone
company
if somebody does something bad over my
airwaves does that make sense that's how
they've got it okay okay
all right
so
fast forward barons and sues baronsonv
twitter
here's what i had
i had
conversa and i had emails from a guy
inside twitter named brandon borman who
is a pretty senior executive he was
their vice president of communications
telling me explicitly
hey
we know what you're saying
we are in favor of encouraging debate
about covid that was in 2020 and then in
early 2021 he even went on to say we're
encouraging debate about the vaccines
and we don't think you're doing anything
wrong
so
so i said
not only are they violating my rights as
a you know as an american
and you know the california constitution
actually has additional free speech
protections and i think they're
violating those too
they're specifically
they made these promises to me they may
they
they modified their contract with me and
there's a broader point that's important
to everybody
when they say we have a coveted
misinformation policy or we have a
election misinformation policy or you
know pretty soon they'll probably have a
climate change misinformation policy
whatever these policies are that that
govern what you can and can't say on
their platform
they have to follow those
so even if they say their contract and
you know when you you you
if you sign up for twitter you you know
you click on something at the end and
you've signed a contract with them
basically and that contract is written
by their lawyers it's very favorable to
them very unfavorable to you as the user
they're modifying that
okay
that was our argument they are modifying
that when they put out a covet 19
misinformation policy they don't have to
have a covert 19 misinformation policy
they could say hey we're twitter we're
going to ban you whenever we want for
whatever reason
but
they did have that policy and our
argument was they have to now
follow it and the judge
his name is judge wilson william allsup
he was in california and he is not a
trump appointee he's not a george bush
appointee he is a bill clinton appointee
known for being a smart guy who kind of
plays it down the middle
he
in april of this year just a couple
months ago said
i think barrington's got a case i'm
going to allow this lawsuit to proceed
i'm not going to dismiss it and that was
a that was a
major event you know and sort of the
point of view of internet law
because again
even though i did have these
communications with borman that other
people
uh don't have this broader issue of who
is
of of whether or not these platforms
when they tell you we're going to have
this strike policy we're going to do
these things do they have to follow that
that's the question again if if the if
the argument is i'm twitter or i'm
facebook i'm all powerful
i operate under 230 and i'm going to
kick you off whenever they want they
gotta tell people that instead it's like
well as long as you play within the
rules and you color by our guidelines
it's okay
and then they don't even do that now you
can sue them
so
you sue
and then did they settle
so so i sue in december
in april we get this ruling and the
judge doesn't allow everything to
proceed which from my point of view was
sort of unfortunate he didn't allow uh
my big claims on the first amendment or
my california claims to proceed and
frankly i still think there's a chance
uh whether it's me or you know it's or
it's not me but whether it's somebody
else somebody else going forward might
be able to have a good claim on
california constitutional law because
again twitter's based in california and
the california constitution is even more
protective of free speech
than um
than the u.s constitution it actually
says for example the way it's been
interpreted in california the california
constitution if you own a mall
you have to let people come in and
protest even if they're you know like
from the vietnam war on even though
that's a private facility
you because you're running this place
that's open to the public
and that a lot of people who you know go
to it becomes almost a public facility
for the purposes of the california
constitution and my argument my lawyer's
argument uh is twitter is
twitter is a huge public space it's
referred to itself as a public square
many times it should be forced to do the
same thing under california law and if
the federal law if 230 blocks that now
we have an issue of uh you know does the
federal law go too far and sort of hurt
first amendment protections but put all
that aside judge didn't allow any of
that stuff
but what he did allow was my breach of
contract claim to proceed and he did
something else joe he
he said
this guy is going to get discovery
so discovery is a in is a legal term it
means that the two parties have to
exchange information in a civil lawsuit
so so and it's actually kind of amazing
if you think about this that this is how
this works
the
the
lawyers for you know for twitter we're
going to go to twitter and say you got
to give us all your documents that and
you know that where alex berenson is
named whether that's internal or whether
that's you know pfizer emailing about
him or whatever it is
and we're going to hand that over to his
lawyers so he can help sue us
and i had to do the same thing i mean
for me it's not a big deal you know it's
like me and my phone or whatever but but
just and then he said the judge said
i would get to depose
two twitter executives and that could be
anybody he didn't put any limits on it
so that could have been like jack dorsey
okay
so if you're a big company that's a
nightmare for you you do not want that
you do not have to go through discovery
you do not want to have to go through
depositions you just want uh
you you want a lawsuit to go away
okay so
and my position was
look
the judge gave me this stuff i'm not
backing off i want those depositions i
want this discovery
and i want the right to make it public
and so
twitter
i did not think we were going to be able
to settle
but twitter
uh
and i in june we had these this long
mediation and i can't sort of talk about
how that went specifically but i can
tell you that at the end of well july
6th they
they they reinstated me to the platform
we settled
they
i guess you could argue they didn't
apologize but they acknowledged they
were wrong to have taken me off
last august and and this is the really
good part
since then i've been publishing internal
documents where twitter
says that they came under pressure from
the federal government to ban me
so
this to me so people said when i settled
it was funny it was actually people on
the right they said this guy
he took all this money to sue twitter he
didn't care he just wanted to get back
on the platform he just wanted to be
able to tweet he wanted some money from
twitter that's what he got he promised
you he'd get discovery he didn't get it
nothing nothing's ever going to happen
with this well
screw those people too okay because i've
now been publishing documents that show
that the white house
wanted me banned and that is the biggest
part of all of this okay that's where
the story is going now
that people inside the white house this
is
and this is this is twitter employees
talking to each other about a meeting
that they had in april of 2021
before twitter had ever done anything to
me
where they said they said that the white
house said why is this guy still allowed
to tweet and at that time
they were saying to each other these
twitter employees we think he's fine we
don't think he's doing anything wrong
well you fast forward to july of 2021
just over a year ago and joe biden says
the vax anybody who debates the vaccines
if social media platforms allow that
they are quote unquote killing people
and then
less or barely a month after that
four hours after that i should say
twitter puts a strike against me they
begin the process of de-platforming me
six weeks later
they d-platform me